[音楽]
私たちはですねできるだけこう気候変動を
起こさないような対策をどんどん進めて
いかないとならない状況になっていますで
もそのそもそも気候変動ってどうやって
起こるんだっけというその仕組みですね
その仕組みを理解しておかないとその有効
な対策のアイデアっていうのはなかなか出
てこない思い浮かばないと思うんですね
ですから今日は私の方からですね
普段皆さんあまり見聞きすることがないで
あろうその少し詳しい気候変動の仕組みに
ついて簡単に解説をしていきたいという
ふうに思います
で気候変動の対策気候変動の仕組みですね
ということいろいろ考えなければいけない
気候変動の話をするときにまず最初に
持ち出されるのはだいたいその気温がどう
変化してるかという話になってると思うん
ですねでもそれは実は結構話が飛躍しすぎ
ていて
気温が変化するっていうのは気候変動の
結果なんですねそのプロセスを考えないと
いけないそうじゃないとどういう仕組みで
起こってるかって理解することはできませ
んその理解する上で一番最初に考える
スタートポイントとなるのが
太陽の光地球がどれぐらい受け取るかと
いうことと地球がどれぐらい赤外線を出す
かそのバランスを考えるということが
考える思考のスタートの地点になるわけ
です
で地球には太陽の光が入ってくるわけです
けれどもそこでまずその一部はですね
空気に大気に浮かんでいる雲それから地面
まで届いて地面で反射されるものその雲と
か地面とか海とかで反射されるものはもう
そのまま
宇宙に戻っていきますから地球が受け取っ
たことにはならないわけですじゃあ
受け取る分はどれかっていうと空気中で
吸収される分とあと地面とか海が吸収する
そういったものが結果的に今地球が
太陽光を受け取る分ということになるわけ
です
一方その地球から出ていくものについては
その熱という形で出てくるものもあります
が多くはその赤外線という形で出ていき
ます
でこの地球から出た赤外線っていうのは実
は空気中で空気中の物質によって一旦多く
がほとんどが吸収されその
吸収した赤外線がその物質からまた
いろんな方向に出るということですそう
いう何回か繰り返してバランスを取って
いくことになるわけですでその空気中の
物質から出るときには上にも行くし下にも
行くいろんな方向に赤外線が出ていくこと
になるわけです
でそのバランスを考えるわけですけども
結果的に今現在の気候はそのバランスが
少しだけずれているつまりここで言うと
この
図で言うと地球が受け取る太陽の光の理は
240という単位である一方地球が出す
宇宙に出していく赤外線の量っていうのは
結果的に239ぐらいこれが今238
ぐらいになっているという風に考えられ
てるんですけども少しだけずれていると
いうことなんですねバランスの崩れこれが
まず気候変動の仕組みを考えるでの
スタート地点になるわけです
で今空気中で何かしらの物質によって赤外
線が吸収されもう1回出るという話をし
ましたその何かしらの物質っていうのが
いわゆる
温室効果ガスというものになるわけです
代表的なものが二酸化炭素
CO2ということです
で海とか陸とか大気から出た赤外線って
いうのはそのほとんどが
温室効果ガスに吸収されてその温室効果
ガスからまた赤外線が出るということに
なってるわけですねそういう仕組みで
バランスを保とうとするわけです
しかしその人間活動によってこのように
温室効果ガスが増加するそうするとどう
なるかというと
その
吸収されない分っていうのが
減って赤外線が余分に
吸収されることになるわけですそうすると
地球の外へ出てくる赤外線の量が減って
しまうわけですね
ででも入ってくる太陽の光の量ってのは
変わらないわけですよそれ潰瘍がない
ということはやっぱりどうしても地球の外
へ出す赤外線の量というのを元に戻したい
ということになるわけですね元に戻さない
といけないことなわけです
CO2が増えた状態であっても
じゃあどうしたらいい
かってここでちょっと難しい法則がある
ステファンボルツマンの法則って言うん
ですけどもこれは
短く言うとあらゆるものから地球の
あらゆるものから赤外線とは全部出てるん
ですね人間からも出てます
その出ていくエネルギーの量は
温度が高いほど多いとエネルギー量が多い
という法則があるんですね例えばこの法則
を生かしたものは実はここのすぐそこに
待ってこの中で広まった非接触の体温計
あれっていうのは人間が出す赤外線の量を
感知してそれで太陽に換算してるわけです
ねこれがまた今度ステファンボルツマンの
使った機械です
その法則をこの気候変動に当てはめて考え
てみると今言ったように
CO2が増えて宇宙に出ていく赤外線の量
が減ってしまいましたでもやっぱり増やし
たい太陽の入ってくる光の量は変わらない
とすることは今のこの法則を当てはめて
考えると
温度が
上がれば地球が出す赤外線の量は増える
わけですねこれが気温が上がるという現象
になってるわけです
じゃあこの気温を上げるためには熱が必要
ですねそれどこから来るかっていうとこれ
が
海とか
陸には大量に
熱が蓄えられてますから空気にとっては
ほんのちょっと
陸とか海から
熱をおすそ分けしてもらえれば簡単に気温
は上がりますでその下から上の空気の中で
対流ですねそれによってまあ気温が上がる
という現象が起こるそれによって赤外線の
出てくる量自体はなんとか元に戻したいと
いう方向に働いてくれるわけですでも結果
的に気温が上がってますこれが今
起こっている地球温暖化の仕組みになる
わけです
で今は
温室効果ガスの説明をしましたけどもそれ
以外にも気候変動を起こす物質ってのは
いくつかありますその代表例がPM2.5
皆さん知ってますね大気汚染を引き起こし
ます
実はPM2.5大気中の微粒子
エアロゾルというんですけどもこれは大気
汚染を起こすんですけども
太陽光のバランスこちら赤外線じゃなくて
太陽光のバランスを変えて気候変動を
起こすという風に考えられてますで一つは
PM2.5濃度が高いと空気が白っぽく
見えますねあれは太陽の光を余分に反射し
てるっていう現象になるわけです
つまり余分に反射してるっていうことは
太陽の光のバランスを崩していることに
なるわけですね
これはつまり気候変動が起こしてるという
ことになるわけですですからPM2.5は
大気汚染も起こすし気候変動も起こすとで
微粒子の中には白っぽいものであったりと
か黒とか茶色とか色ついたものがあります
色がついたものはその
太陽の光を吸収するという性質もあるん
ですけれどもまあ結果的には太陽の光の
エネルギーのバランスを崩すということに
結果的にはなるわけです
でもう1個
空気中には大気中には普通に雲が浮かんで
ますね何気なく皆さん見てると思います
けども
雲というのはそもそもPM2.5のような
微粒子が空気中にないと絶対に
雲は存在しないんですね
雲は最初その微粒子に水蒸気がくっつく
ことによって
初めてできるんですねすいちっちゃい水滴
ができるわけです
ということは
雲の性質を微粒子が例えば人間活動によっ
て増えていくと
雲の性質を変える可能性があるということ
になるわけです
で雲というのは
太陽の光をすごく反射してくれますね効率
的に
雲の下だったら日陰ができて涼しいですね
で雲というのは効率的に太陽の光が反射
するのでその雲の性質が変われば当然その
太陽の光のエネルギーも当然変わるわけ
バランスが変わってしまうということに
なるわけですでこれらの現象によってその
大気汚染を起こしつつ気候変動も起こすと
いう物質もあるんですね
そこが大きなポイントです実は私はここの
研究の重点的に行っていて実は福岡の皆
さんだったらPM2.5の予測っていうの
を見たことがどっかあるかもしれませんが
多分おそらくそれは私が毎日してるもの私
が開発したソフトウェアを使ってその予測
を皆さんに使っていただけるという形を今
取っています
でこれまとめですけれどもこれはですね
具体的にじゃあどれぐらい
量的にその人間が余分に出した物質によっ
てエネルギーの
太陽光とか赤外線のバランスが崩れている
かということを示したもので一番やっぱり
メインは二酸化炭素CO2これは空気を
加熱する方向に働いてます
でそれ以外にも大きなものとして温室効果
ガスとしてメタンというものがありますで
メタンの排出源は化石燃料もあるんです
けどもちょっと得意で
農業分野例えば家畜とか水田とか次にあの
星野さんの声の中で出てきますけど廃棄物
そういったものが発生源になっています
でメタンが増えると実はさらにもう一個の
温室効果ガスオゾンも増える
オゾンというのは
温室効果ガスであるかつ大気汚染物質これ
は高価格オキシダントの主な物質はオゾン
ですですからこれもまた大気汚染を起こす
気候変動も起こす物質で良いことはないと
いうことになるわけです
それからフロンガスというものもあります
ねフロンガスは
昔のフロンガスはオゾン数を壊すという
性質があってそれらは今使うことが禁止さ
れていますけれども今はだいたいフロンと
いうものが使われてますエアコンとか冷蔵
庫とかで冷媒として使われてますけれども
まあそういったものは実はいずれにしても
温室効果ガスなんですね
なので
漏れてはいけないということになるわけ
です
で最後に先ほどお話しした
待機中の微粒子PM2.5というのは物質
っていうのは実は逆に空気を冷やす効果が
あるんですね
ということはどういうことかっていうと今
まで大気汚染対策をしてPM2.5先進国
は減らしてきましたでもCO2は出し続け
ました
結果的にどういうことが起こるかというと
冷やしてくれてたものがだけ減らして
温めるものだけ増やしちゃってるで温暖化
を加速する方向に我々は持ってってしまっ
たっていうのが実は現実問題としてあるん
ですね
なのでその
環境問題をトータルとして考えた場合には
その
CO2一辺倒ではなくていろんな物質に
よっていろんな気候変動が起こって
るってことをトータルに考えて対策を取っ
ていく必要があるということが言えると
思います以上で私からの
プレゼン終わりにしますありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]
[音楽]